[Musique]
devant les étrangers de particulière
complexité aujourd'hui il ya eu plus de
130 modifications depuis 20 ans du code
des étrangers évidemment on a peut
supprimer on a beaucoup rajouté dans ces
conditions les agents des préfectures se
trouve face à des problématiques
extrêmement lourde qui sont des
problématiques du quotidien la demande
de rendez vous en préfecture aujourd'hui
été numérisés c'est parfait on à
éliminer les files d'attentes des gens
devant les préfectures en revanche le
système s'est retrouvé très vite bloqué
ça a généré des procédures devant
tribunal administratif évidemment et
donc y compris les magistrats nous ont
dit mais on a l'impression de faire le
secrétariat de la préfecture le rapport
prévoit au delà du constat plus de 32
recommandations dont une concernant le
principe dit 360 degrés qui était une
préconisation du conseil d'état en 2020
qui vise à ce que le siège de préfecture
étudie l'ensemble du dossier d'un
demandeur étrangers pour adapter le type
de séjour à la réalité des situations en
moyenne 40% du travail des tribunaux
ministre hâtif concerne le droit des
étrangers c'est considérable première
chose il ya 12 procédures possibles
aujourd'hui dans notre droit positif le
rapport du conseil d'état préconise
trois procédures et donc nous la
reprenons à notre compte et nous
proposons effectivement que cela sous
change et que à travers un nouveau texte
nouvelle loi on met en place ces trois
procédures et en limitent à trois
procédures la possibilité pour saisir le
tribunal alors au plan européen la
difficulté est un peu de nature
différente la situation actuelle fait
que lé système est peu applicable on ne
renvoie pas dans les pays de premières
entrée pour faire très simple que par
ailleurs les délais explose au faire
cela et à la sortie ce système ne
fonctionne plus donc il faut tout
remettre à plat repenser complètement
les accords de dublin
pour essayer à l'échelle européenne de
trouver une solution qui soit
opérationnel le renvoie dans les pays
sources est également fondamentale et on
est bloqué parce qu'on n'obtient pas des
pays sources ils sont la paix les
laissez passer consulaires donc
l'objectif c'est d'essayer de les
contraindre on établisse un rapport à la
fois de concertation de discussions
entre les pays sources et puis peut être
aussi un rapport de force parce que la
situation ne peut pas continuer comme ça